well first of all i loved you in this
film i'm ready to see you as a superhero
let's do it
what like what are we going to do how is
this going to happen i don't know what
is what do we have to do
you tell me what superhero would you
like to play if you could play anyone
i mean the one i always thought was the
coolest was ghost rider okay but i
always felt like that was taken
you know
you know
but i wonder what i just don't know what
the waiting period is on that
you know
obviously
you know ava's giving it her blessing
she's she's
she's cool but you know there's a lot of
i need the blessing from a lot of other
people yeah i need kevin's
nick cage the marvel fans that's there's
a there's a checklist that has to happen
and i don't if you want to if you can
the petition put in a word or something
i will call a friend okay like period um
chris was also a really good villain
which was unexpected yeah what was it
like sparring with him in this
you know chris ran mustache first
into this role
and he had a lot of fun playing it and
uh i you know it was a lot of fun to
play against that yeah
yeah what was it like training as well
did you have injuries
because you kicked ass there was a lot
it was a it was a knock down drag out
type of
day every day you know there were there
were cuts and bruises but no emotional
scars
that have surfaced yet
um there's a lot of training you know
was it was um
you know all that stuff you look you
lift heavy things you don't eat certain
things we all know that stuff it's
boring but i think what i didn't realize
was was how many people it takes to make
an action hero you know like i had an
incredible team of stunt performers that
were
making me look like i could do what i
was doing and i had a special effects
team doing it too
and then uh i also had this this really
really helpful advisor who was like an
ex delta force member and he was with me
on every scene
but he had great ideas like
you know you should always have skittles
on you you know because it's a great
source of energy and you know they don't
expire and it's like okay and then like
tie your shoelace to the door when you
sleep because you know you'll know when
someone comes in the room
all this stuff that you know uh was not
in the script but i thought just like
you would only know it from experience
yeah and just made the movie so much
more interesting and yeah well this
movie was fantastic i honestly loved it
and i loved you in it um
people are so excited about you and
barbie i was expecting barbie here right
now i'm not gonna lie okay i see the tan
the glow okay it's present okay it's
nice of you the hair to notice yeah and
i know that your partner is excited
about it it's energy that's what you're
feeling
energy yeah i think it's what you're
describing
it hashtag
i love it here
we're all super excited about it but i
know your partner is the most excited
about it and i like hearing her
talk about you
in barbie uh-huh like that's the best
part because she doesn't
speak very often right to the press but
when she does it's all about you and
it's a lot of
positive things yeah she wanted she knew
she saw my ken underwear she wanted a
pair
okay brought him home
like that i have underwear that says can
on them you know she's like very she
feels the energy too
and she got the she got the underwear um
i'm so happy for you guys
it was so nice talking to you canadian
you're such a young legend we love you i
got some canadian stuff oh my gosh
somebody brought me
all dressed chips yes do you have
ketchup what's that no you know i don't
no okay we'll make a call
i am a fan though after the marvel call
okay we got a lot of work i did i'm
sorry that's a lot going on that was a
lot it was a lot i'm sorry thank you
that's too much uh responsibility you
don't have to do any of that okay okay i
will though